so walk me through the logistics of was
it 30 days you were there did you ever
get access to a phone how did you keep
your makeup looking so good in that heat
I can assure you I didn't day yeah so
basically we weren't allowed any contact
with the outside world it was just like
you know in the villa you're being
tested your willpower is being tested
you've got to connect with each other on
earth on a very deep emotional level and
whilst doing that you're kind of
figuring stuff out about your own self
and finding out what stops you from
finding love in the outside world and
why haven't I be able when I which is to
stay in a relationship with a sick guy
from a club or why has that guy just
slept with me but doesn't wanna talk to
me again and it's like the whole process
you've got to trust and us not being
able to have gone on our phones and just
being an isolated environment images
I wouldn't expect the show to work if we
did have our phones so how long were you
there for and then how long did you have
to keep others a secret so we filmed for
around a month and it was the most
amazing month of my life I've met so
many wonderful people we had to keep
this a secret for around a year how hard
was that well I have a best friend that
I met in the villa and Nicole she is
just my soul mate I love her so much and
not being able to post pictures of me
and my best friend even though we see
each other all the time
is just like I is just crazy you've just
got to keep it a secret like oh I just
can't explain it who else are you
staying in touch with from the show
so to be honest I'm talking to everyone
everyone is just like a massive family
we went through such a rollercoaster on
the show and I think it would be such a
shame if none of us were talking I mean
we went first very much together and it
was just it's just amazing that we're
all talking still so are you at all
nervous for your family to watch because
you do certainly talk about how much you
want to hook up when you get put in a
villa you look sexy people
there's six-packs everywhere so you're
gonna look less and there's a six-pack
you look right there's a six-pack and my
family when they watch the show they're
going to be proud of me they are going
to be proud of me because I didn't do
like hanky panky
really maybe tiny bit I mean it was just
me and there wasn't any cringe-worthy
moments I don't think I mean I would
never regret anything not done in the
villa so you don't wish you'd done
anything different I mean you were
smitten with Cory so do you wish you
done anything different there or
anything different with Bryce wait in
terms of price I followed my heart and
my head they were both battling so I'd
never met Cory before when Bryce came in
and I thought to myself he's a really
nice guy but he's just not my type
really and I kind of give him a go and
we had like chats I got to know him a
bit more give him the benefit of the
doubt and I did explain to him that I
was very real opening on a surprise and
when Cory came in it was like he's a
gator he's my type I am going to be
smitten this is my sleeve this is me
putting my heart on my sleeve with Cory
and I was absolutely heartbroken with
Cory when he chose
I'll go to college because I just felt
like I've chucked nice price away for
you and you've kind of like just it's
kicked me to decide what is wrong with
me okay so tomorrow if you're back in
the villa and you have one night in the
villa and Lana tells you you can
actually hook up with anyone tonight or
no one at all what do you do I would see
who comes to me oh I'm not chasing
anyone I mean I'm all about women
howlman since the show it's taught me
love yourself queen-like know your where
don't chase the guy don't sit there and
let someone muck you are and not be
truthful to you being real love yourself
you don't need a man to find and feel
that missing piece
it's literally that's all the shoulders
taught me to love myself you in the
beginning you really kind of called
yourself an airhead and you did poke fun
at yourself do you do those things
anymore do you find yourself putting
your yourself down a little bit less now
I'm not naive to the fact that I am a
little bit dumb in the show it was kind
of obvious that the people that I was
surrounded with we're slightly more
intelligent than me however I think it
is an insecurity of mine and I feel
instead of to cry about it just laugh
about it and before going into there at
the show and going through that
experience I kind I was just used to
used to people saying oh you're just
stupid or that just not listening to
anything that I had to say and going for
the experience of the show has just made
me feel like I am enough just because I
don't know max or times tables I know
that I am connected inside and I am
emotionally more away
you